2016 une année marquée par les
manifestations contre la loi travail
dévoilé en février la réforme du code du
travail porté par myriam el khomri a
fait naître de nombreuses critiques
les syndicats cgt et fo en tête se
mobilisent ils seront rejoints par le
mouvement citoyen nuit debout et par les
étudiants
c'est la base même du projet de loi qui
nous convient pas c'est l'esprit même de
cette loi qui vise à libéraliser encore
un peu plus un marché du travail qui
vise à augmenter la précarité des jeunes
est donc temps l'esprit même de cette
loi on peut pas l'accepter comme
l'ensemble des secteurs aujourd'hui on
est attaqué violemment conçoit cheminots
qu'on travaille dans d'autres secteurs
et aujourd'hui le combat contre al waha
travail c'est un peu une occasion de
fédérer un peu tous les mécontentements
qui sont en train de s'exprimer dans
tous les secteurs aux chemins de fer
comme ailleurs et cette manifestation
aujourd'hui la en est l'expression au
terme de cinq mois de protestations la
loi travail a été adopté en juillet sans
vote à l'issue d'un troisième recours à
l'article 49 3
une année encore sous menace terroriste
le 13 juin 2016 un couple de policiers
est assassiné à l'armé blanche à
magnanville leur fils trois ans au
moment des faits est sain et sauf
le meurtrier l'a rossi à bala
appartenaient à l'organisation
terroriste état islamique
il a été tué lors de l'assaut lancé par
le raid l'émotion était palpable
j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer vos
policiers
notre immense tristesse
toute notre compassion dans le de leur
dire la solidarité de la république dans
toutes ses forces se rassembler je suis
extrêmement choquée puisqu'on a atteint
on a fait à tintin aux valeurs de la
république et surtout parce que je suis
extrêmement en colère je pense surtout à
cet enfant de trois ans qui se
retrouvent orphelins c'est très triste
ça pourrait arriver à n'importe qui j'ai
l'impression qu'on est plus en sécurité
ici le 31 mai les yvelines était sous
les eaux de nombreuses communes ont été
touchées par des inondations dans les
champs les récoltes ont été ravagées
les agriculteurs avaient reçu le soutien
du conseil départemental
en décembre le conseil départemental
avec la chambre d'agriculture d'île de
france a débloqué une aide de 400 mille
euros
plus de 600 exploitations céréalières
vont en bénéficier cette année 2016
c'est aussi le rapprochement et le
projet de fusion entre yvelines et
hauts-de-seine conséquence des baisses
de dotations de l'état
une fusion qui vise donc à réaliser des
économies en mutualisant leurs services
en mars les deux départements ont créé
un établissement public de coordination
interdépartementale le 30 juin sept pays
et fenêtres site alios un nouvel
aménageur franciliens ses missions ça va
être de trop service des communes en
particulier et de leur apporter toutes
les compétences avec en même temps
toute la réflexion que nous allons
conduire et qui sera une réflexion qui
sera plutôt dans une philosophie de
liberté des collectivités locales que
dans celle du la centralisation étatiste
dire est développé par grand paris
aménagements après bonnel en septembre
2015 l'accueil des migrants dans les
yvelines s'est renforcé en 2016
plusieurs centres ont vu le jour malgré
différentes manifestations notamment à
versailles à rocquencourt une
quarantaine de migrants sont installés
sur le site de l'inria depuis novembre
suite au démantèlement d'un camp un pari
maurepas a elle aussi accueilli une
centaine de personnes en novembre mais
avec un début houleux les élus avaient
d'abord manifesté leur opposition
je suis très en colère parce que
maurepas a déjà rempli son devoir
d'humanité pour accueillir des débits
grand l'été dernier au gymnase des
baissière et une seconde fois l'état
réquisitionne ce bâtiment en pleine
année scolaire par un accord avec la
mairie et les autorités de l'état les
migrants étaient finalement logé dans la
salle des fêtes
en novembre les yvelines accueillait au
total 400 migrants